it might have been oliver stone who was  here i saw that so that was really  interesting i'm not sure if you've ever  worked with oliver known or been in the  middle i know a little bit about it i'm  sure you do yeah yeah uh and i remember  i said who does he want to emulate who  who are his heroes is it is it stalin is  it len and he goes no no no no no no  he older than that mother russia i think  he said peter the great  and this is what year were peter the  great i mean this is czarist russia in  the 1600s so when we talk about what his  i do think he loves his country i don't  think there's any doubt he loves russia  um  when but when we think of russia and the  russia that he loves it's not soviet  communist red russia of the 1930s  it's the  1630s 1730s whatever you're what you're  as peter the great  okay early 1700s  uh  that is the greatness that putin wants  to  bring to it's the first thing i said  peter the great was six eight wow